so you now have two very similar
problems
for genome assembly but it turned out
that these two problems
had very different algorithmic fades
in the already past problem we want to
find a path
visiting every edge of the graph exactly
once
in the hamiltonian path problem we want
to find the path visiting
every node exactly once it sounds like a
small cosmetic and unimportant
difference
let me ask you a question if you were
given the possibility to choose
between the hamiltonian past problem and
already in past problem
as presented at this slide what
choice would you make sean well i would
like to
solve the eulerian path problem because
the graph
on the right looks simpler and maybe
it's easier to find a path that
traverse all the edges in the graph
sean just gave a very wrong
answer it doesn't matter that
one graph looks simpler than another in
real life
this graph will contains millions if not
billions of edges and it doesn't matter
that one of them contains two millions
and another contains one million of
edges
what matter is whether we have efficient
algorithms for solving these problems
and it turned out that the different
algorithmic
fate of this problem was related is
related to the fact that
euler actually found an algorithm
for efficiently solving cholera and past
problem
but a generation of computer scientists
failed
to find an efficient algorithm for
hamiltonian path problem
in fact the hamiltonian path problem
belongs
to a class of so-called np complete
problems
that contain thousands of computational
for which algorithms are still unknown
for some time computer scientists try to
find out
whether this problem can be solved in
principle well or
whether there are if maybe there is not
even any
efficient algorithm for solving this
problem maybe even god cannot solve this
problem efficiently
but it turned out to be very difficult
to prove
that there is no efficient algorithm for
this problem and in fact
the hamiltonian path problem belonged
to one of seven millennium problem of
mathematics that remains
op however what computer scientists were
able to prove is that all np complete
problems which means
thousands of problems from this class
are equivalent
or in other words if you solve
any of this problem you will solve the
hamiltonian path problem
and as a result our failure to solve the
becomes a little bit less upsetting
because we know that we failed to solve
it
but we also know that thousands of
computer scientists
also failed to solve it and since
our chances to solve this problem are
slim
from now on we will focus on the already
path problem and we'll study it in more
details